on imagine encore trouve souvent
l'europe comme un concept une nébuleuse
tout se passe loin de chez nous pourtant
l'europe c'est du concret avec des
projets des structures que l'on retrouve
un peu partout
encore faut-il les identifier au plan
local ou écouter à vrai dire j'en sais
rien il suffit de chercher des indices
sur les bâtiments comme ces panneaux
bleu étoilé ainsi il ya dix ans l'europe
à cofinancer la médiathèque de mâcon à
c'est super je ne savais pas mais bon
c'est vrai que je viens d'un petit
village donc c'est agréable varinard
nouvelle médiathèque comme ça je serai
pas mal finance beaucoup de choses des
choses intéressantes et pas toujours
mais non là là là oui c'est un c'est un
bon financement là lorsque la mairie de
mâcon un budgétisé son projet de
médiathèque à hauteur de 9 millions six
cent mille euros
elle a décidé de chercher des
subventions pour faire face à cette très
grosse dépense et c'est notamment
l'union européenne qui a répondu
présente avec un million huit cent mille
euros t il est évident qu si amiens
800000 euros n'étaient pas intervenues
il y avait deux solutions soit la ville
empruntez 1 millions 8,2 plus dur était
extrêmement compliqué soit on réduisait
la tête le volume du projet ce qui
aurait été un peu compliqué pour les
utilisateurs je pense que grâce à
l'europe en est arrivé à faire un
bâtiment finançable par la ville donc
acceptable par le contribuable et très
sécurisant pour le personnel est
acceptable pour les usagers avec ses
3500 m² de surfaces utiles ces espaces
d'exposition de travail
la médiathèque de mâcon a très vite fait
oublier ses anciens locaux exigus
je trouve que c'est un lieu où vient
toutes sortes de gens c'est un refuge
pour la tête pour or pour la vie
par exemple là j'ai rencontré un jeune
qui viennent côte du mois que je à qui
je donne un coup de main et les
mâconnais apprécie tellement l'endroit
que les inscriptions ont explosé oui
c'était flagrant je me souviens plus
précisément mais je crois qu'on était
quatre mille personnes inscrites et on
est passé très vite à assimile donc
c'était énorme
il y avait une attente un très clair
d'un bâtiment et d'un équipement digne
de ce nom pour la lecture publique un
mac ou l'europe a donc participé au
développement de la culture en bourgogne
du sud
et cet exemple est loin d'être un cas
isolé